was there a key decision that you look
back on and say okay this is what led to
then b c and d and has got me here yeah
when I was six years old my mother
decided that I could stay up late to
watch Star Trek and that that literally
is is where it all started for me
because that show I'm talking with the
original Star Trek that show just opened
my eyes to a world other than what i saw
in front of me every day as a little kid
and I think that's where my imagination
really started to to reach out and then
see what what I could envision and then
somebody gave me a book called the
making of Star Trek remind you I was way
too young to read this very dry
technical books like I went to the
picture section and the very first
picture in the photo section of the
making of Star Trek is these a 1960s
studio technicians doing some sort of
work on the bridge of the enterprise and
it's something just clicked in my head
you know I wanted to be mr. Spock or
Captain Kirk but I knew that wasn't real
and that was about the limit of my
understanding at that age and then here
were these real people working on the
bridge of the enterprise and and
something just clicked for me like there
is a way to work on the enterprise I can
go do that you know and over the next
five or ten years of childhood and
adolescence there were a lot of
different things that I thought maybe I
would do when I grew up but but that
always stuck with me and so and so the
key moment with my mom letting me stay
up to watch Star Trek you're probably
not looking for that
you